I'm Paul Kennedy this is ideas war and
violence have always been with us
the first murder took place between the
first humans Cain and Abel and that
legacy of destroying ourselves and each
other has come down to us from the very
beginning the creation story reminds us
as much about our tragic weakness as it
does about our infinite potential as
humans chaos is transformed into order
by the word and you are all speakers of
the word and if you want chaos to be
transformed into hell then lie if you
want chaos to be transformed into heaven
then tell the truth it's easy to look at
violence and war as anomalies of human
nature but there's clearly something
else going on what's the meaning of the
Columbine and Sandy Hook school
massacres the bus bombings in Jerusalem
the Charlie Hebdo killings sometimes we
think politics can explain these things
or a kind of madness but what else might
be behind such senseless acts acts that
achieve no goal except a universal
sadness about the human condition you
can sweep underneath your bed you don't
have to go out wave a placard around I'm
against poverty it's like who's for
poverty I think you want to fix the
world 6y5 it's a lot harder than you
think right it says in the New Testament
it's harder to rule yourself than to
rule the city but why well turns out
you're more complicated than a city it
also turns out that you're more
important in some sense than a city
Jordan Peterson is a professor of
psychology at the University of Toronto
and a clinical psychologist at the
Stratford Festival he explored some of
these questions and in today's program
we'll hear the talk he gave and the
conversation I had with him afterwards
here's a history of violence
if you do a genuine psychological
analysis of the human thirst for war you
can't entertain a more brutal topic and
part of the reason that people don't
understand it is because you really
don't want to understand it so despite
that I'm going to use a case history
today fundamentally to illustrate the
state of mind that you have to occupy in
order to be willing and ready to commit
any atrocity that might be demanded of
you under any circumstances whatsoever
the best way to think about the human
thirst for war at least at the level of
analysis that I am capable of is to
think about it as a personality lots of
the states of mind that possess us can
be reasonably thought of as a
personality so if you're angry for
example you can think of yourself as
possessed by Ares or Mars who's the God
of War or if you're hopelessly in love
and making a fool of yourself well then
you're possessed by eros or Cupid or
Venus and that really is how archaic
people pre-scientific people viewed the
proclivity of people to occupy states of
mind that were quite different than
those that were characteristic of their
normal personality Freud
really capitalized on that idea and
modernized it in some sense because
Freud viewed the human being as in some
sense a loosely united collection of sub
personalities we don't tend to
conceptualize states of mind anymore as
personalities not in the scientific
literature but we do all the time in
literature and drama and movies and that
sort of representation is extra
nearly compelling weirdly enough you'll
pay to watch it and it is very strange
if you think about it because if the
spectre of pure destructiveness is laid
out in front of you on a stage there's
no logical reason to assume that you
would voluntarily expose yourself to
that to that and pay for the privilege
of doing so but you do and the reason
for that one of the reasons for that is
that you need to know what that
personality is partly so you can
recognize elements of it if they
manifest themselves in front of you or
within you and partly because you really
can't understand good until you
understand evil and so if you're ever
wondering why why good itself seems to
be such a limited resource it's
worthwhile remembering that you don't
get there without going somewhere you
don't want to go first and so that's
where we're going to go today I'm going
to start with a Shakespearean quote
seems appropriate from titus and
dronicus which is a very violent play a
play that's essentially about vengeance
and one of Shakespeare's characters says
why should wrath be mute and fury dumb I
am no baby I that with bass prayers I
should repent the evils I have done ten
thousand worst that ever yet I did would
I perform if I might have my will if one
good deed in all my life I did I do
repent it from my very soul it's not the
sort of thing that you want to hear
someone say to you
we look for reasons why people might be
vote motivated to commit atrocious acts
and given our cultural standpoint at
present we're often looking for
sociological reasons poverty which does
not read violence by the way relative
poverty which does lack of education
ignorance we very seldom consider intent
or voluntary intent because the idea is
that people could voluntarily and
consciously intend destructiveness is a
very frightening thought especially when
you realize that if people could do that
to the degree that you're a person you
could also do that and understanding
that people could do that and that you
could means that you might be morally
obliged to undertake a very thorough
examination of the motives for your own
behavior the personality that I want to
talk to talk about today it's composed
of a downward spiral tonight I think
that's why people people have always
envisioned hell in some sense as a
bottomless pit hell is the bottomless
pit because no matter how bad it is
there's some stupid thing you can do to
make it worse and so the spiraling is
indicative of a positive feedback loop
where a causes B & B causes C and then C
causes a and everything moves out of
control the case study that I want to
present to you today is one of the more
literate of the Columbine killers whose
name was Eric Harris people wonder why
the mass shooters do what they do which
in some sense is quite surprising to me
because if you read what they say they
tell you why they do what they do now
why people don't believe that is not
clear to me except that I think that if
you do
take them at their word raises all sorts
of spectres that we would rather have
hidden Eric Harris became possessed I
would say of his own free choice by a
personality that was composed of
ideological rigidity pride resentment
deception and vengefulness I'm going to
read you some of his comments about
government systems here's Harris's
comments with regards to ideological
rigidity like the early Nazi government
my brain is like a sponge sucking up
everything that sounds cool and leaving
out all that is worthless
that's how Nazism was formed and that's
how I will be - Hitler and his head boys
messed up a few times and it cost them
the war but I love their beliefs and who
they were what they did and what they
wanted
I love the Nazis too by the way I can't
get enough of the swastika the SS and
the iron cross it's not that he didn't
understand the Nazis he understood them
perfectly well whatever else you might
say about Eric Harris he wasn't stupid
pride people parents corpse God teachers
telling me what to do think say act and
everything else just makes me not want
to do it that's why my nickname is rebel
Reb actually no one is worthy of
anything unless I say they are I feel
like God I wish I was having everyone
being officially lower than me I already
know that I'm higher than almost anyone
in the world in terms of universal
intelligence I feel ever more confident
stronger and more godlike and I have
confidence in my ability to deceive
people I have thought too much realize
too much found out too much and I'm too
self-aware to just stop what I am
thinking and go back to society because
what I do and think isn't right or
morally accepted no no no I would sooner
die than betray my own thoughts but
before I leave this worthless place I
will kill whoever I deem unfit for
anything at all
this is from Paradise Lost the great
poem by John Milton these are the words
that he puts into the mouth of Satan
after he's flung from heaven for daring
to oppose and attempt to transcend the
most high as his desire was not only to
be like God but to be superior to God
and in some sense he's a symbol in some
very important sense he's a symbol or a
representation you could say which is
more accurate of the ultimate in
intellectual pride which says everything
I know is sufficient and there's nothing
transcendent beyond that Milton has
Satan say farewell happy fields where
joy forever dwells hail Horrors hail
infernal world and thou profoundest hail
received thy new possessor one who
brings a mind not to be changed by place
or time resentment I've noticed in my
clinical practice that there are two
three character logical elements and
they really do people in and weirdly
enough they're not really listed in the
psychiatric list of diagnosis and
they're often also not discussed as
causal elements in the genesis of mental
illness and suffering even though in my
experience they're actually the primary
causes arrogance which is I already know
enough deceit which is I can twist the
fabric of reality in my favor for my
individual wants and I can get away with
it which goes along with pride and
arrogance and then resentment which is
the world is tragic which is of course
true the world is unjust and tragic
which is more debatable and the
injustice and tragedy of the world is
aimed at me specifically and unfairly
well that's just not true at all
resentment
I hate you people for leaving me out of
so many fun things and no don't say well
that's your fault because it isn't you
people had my phone number and I asked
and all but no no no don't let the
weird-looking Eric kid come along
oh no you people could have shown more
respect treated me better asked for my
knowledge or guidance more treated me
more like a senior and maybe I wouldn't
have been as ready to tear your heads
off
Melton again Paradise Lost has Satan's
say the more I see pleasures about me so
much more I feel torment within me as
from the hateful siege of contraries all
good to me becomes bane and in heaven
much worse would be my state but neither
here seek I know nor in heaven to dwell
and less by mastering heaven supreme nor
hope to be myself less miserable by what
I seek
but others to make such as I though
thereby worse to me redound for only in
destroying do I find ease to my
relentless thoughts Eric Harris again
then again I have always hated how I
looked I make fun of people who look
like me sometimes without even thinking
sometimes just because I want to rip on
myself that's where a lot of hate grows
from this is Richard 3 from Shakespeare
Richard the third
I shall despair there is no creature
loves me and if I die no soul will pity
me nay wherefore should they since that
I myself find in myself no pity to
myself deception you know what I feel
like telling about lies I lie a lot
almost constantly into everybody just to
keep my own ass out of the water and by
the way I don't think I'm doing this for
attention as some people may think let's
see what are some big lies I've told ya
I stopped smoking
yeah I'm sorry for doing it not for
getting caught no I haven't been making
more bombs
no I wouldn't do that and of course
countless other ones yeah I know that I
hate liars and I am one myself oh well
it's okay if I'm a hypocrite but no one
else because I'm higher than you people
no matter what you say and if you
disagree I would shoot you if you take
the personality elements that we've
already discussed and you mix them up
and you let them run as a process you
get the positive feedback loop that I
was describing earlier and it goes
something like this and I learned this
in part from the analysis of the story
of Cain and Abel in in in Genesis the
first story about real human beings is
the story about Cain and Abel because
Adam and Eve were made by God right so
you know you can't really call them
normal humans Cain and Abel are the
first humans and Cain is very resentful
and deceitful and vengeful and the
reason for that from which it's clearly
explained in the story is that Cain
sacrifices aren't accepted by God now
it's hard for modern people to
understand what a sacrifice is because
why why would you offer up to God
some remnant of an animal for example
but you know people along while back
acted things out before they could
understand them and they had a more
concrete view of the world I mean they
assumed God was in the cosmos because if
you look up in the night sky especially
if it's dark it overwhelms you you see
the transcendent and the infinite and so
it's the sensation and experience of
that that allows for the attribution of
God and his dwelling place to the heaven
so that's not so ridiculous because you
do see the infinite when you're out
under this guy at night in the dark and
if God's up there since smoke rises if
you burn something while God can tell if
what you're offering is of quality or
not now we have the psychological
equivalent which is I asked my students
what sacrifices did your parents make so
that you could go to university and of
course they can answer that and no time
flat and whether that sacrifice worked
depends on how well the child does at
university but what that essentially
means is that
the sacrifice of the parents found favor
well with reality but you can substitute
God for that with no loss of meaning and
so modern people obviously believe that
if you sacrifice properly then reality
will shine its benevolent face on you
otherwise we wouldn't work so we're not
so different from those archaic people
now Cain makes sacrifices and God
doesn't like them now the story's a bit
ambivalent about why it might just be
that God's arbitrary I mean it there's
no shortage of arbitrariness on the part
of God in the Old Testament which is
part of the reason that people have
modern people have trouble with that
book because they say well I could never
believe in a God who's that arbitrary or
even cruel but the ancient Israelites
weren't that foolish they knew that life
could be that arbitrary and cruel no
matter what you believe so it could be
that god it just has it in for Cain or
it could be that Cain is just not really
offering up the best quality sacrifices
and so he's trying to pull one over on
God and everyone else and in fact that
is what God accuses him of if you read
the story very carefully Cain is mad
because Abel's getting everything and
everyone loves Abel lots of crops his
flocks are flourishing all the girls
love him plus he's a really good guy so
you can't even hate him with good
conscience which is extremely annoying
especially to Cain so King goes and has
a chat with God he says what kind of
stupid place have you made here
he means reality I'm like working myself
to the bone and you know all I get is
the dregs and then there's old Abel out
there and you know everything he touches
turns to gold what's up with you which
is kind of arrogant if you think about
it right because he is talking to God
after all it isn't clear that Cain
understands everything about being and
there's always the possibility that it's
Cain's fault - not gods but that isn't a
hypothesis that Cain is willing to
entertain so God says to him basically
sin which means to miss the bullseye by
the way crouches at your doorstep like a
predatory and sexually aroused hunting
cat and you invited in and let it have
its way with you by which he means not
only is Cain attacked by sin so to speak
but that it's a creative Union sort of
attack sin comes in and Cain plays with
it and develops it and puts his own
twist on it he produces something new
out of it it's obvious decane that God
isn't willing to take responsibility for
the terrible state of being as a
consequence of this accusation and that
makes him extremely mad extremely mad
and he kills Abel
and then if you follow the story closely
you can see that God tells everyone else
to leave Cain alone don't don't kill him
and the reason for that is that there's
a propensity for that kind of vengeful
killing to expand exponentially out into
the community which in fact is what
happens in the story of Cain and Abel
and the end the the last one of Cain's
descendants named is actually tubal Cain
and he is by tradition the first person
who makes weapons of war so the idea is
that individual resentment manifested as
homicidal rage is the precondition for
the spread of that mode of being into
the broader community and the danger
there is that will degenerate into
everyone against everyone Harris
moral is just another word and that's it
I think we are all a waste of natural
resources and should be killed off and
since humans have the ability to choose
and I'm human I think I will choose to
kill and damage as much as nature allows
me so take that eat napalm and lead
someone's bound to say what were they
thinking when we go natural-born killers
or when we're planning it so this is
what I'm thinking I have a goal to
destroy as much as possible so I must
not be sidetracked by my feelings of
sympathy mercy or any of that keep this
in mind I want to burn the world now
part of the reason that
and kills Abel is because Abel is
favored by God and so Cain is actually
not only taking revenge against Abel and
against his own insufficiency and he
gets suffering he's actually taking
revenge against God and being itself and
that's actually what he wants to do hate
I'm full of hate and I love it I want to
grab some weak little freshmen and tear
them apart like a wolf show them who's
God strangle them squash their head bite
their temples into the skull rip off
their jaw rip off their collarbones
break their arms in half and twist them
around the lovely sounds of Bones
cracking and flesh ripping so much to do
in so little chance god I want a torch
and level everything in this whole area
but bones of that size are hard to make
plus I would need a fully loaded a-10 to
get every store on wodsworth in all the
buildings downtown picture half of
Denver on fire just for me and vodka who
was his partner napalm on sides of
skyscrapers and car garages blowing up
from exploded gas tanks oh man that
would be beautiful yes the human race is
still indeed doomed it just needs a few
Kickstarter's like me if i can wipe a
few cities off the map then great if you
recall your history the nazis came up
with a final solution to the Jewish
problem kill them all
well in case you haven't figured it out
yet I say kill mankind
no one should survive so I'll close this
brief case history with a quote from
Goethe from Faust and in Faust the
figure of Satan is played by methis da
Felice and Memphis da fleas in Bertha's
formulation is a very arrogant intellect
and he has a credo which is the
articulated formulation of the values
that he lives by the spirit I that
endlessly denies and rightly to for all
that comes to birth is fit for overthrow
nothing worth where for the world were
better sterilized thus all that's here
is evil recognized is gain to me and
downfall rude and sinned the very
element I prosper in so you can see in
that the actuality the actuality is not
only what Harris wrote and meant but
also what he did and what he was
planning to do which was much more
destructive than what he actually
managed you see his state of possession
by a set of infinitely destructive
desires and wishes and you see the
continual representation of that pattern
of action and thought in literature
that's evil versus good
classically that's what the world is
that's what the cosmos is it's a place
where evil and good continually battle
eternally battle and although we don't
believe in such things anymore or more
accurately we don't know what we believe
we still are inclined to watch that
drama present itself on stage in endless
variations and the reason for that is
that it's true you can't understand the
human capacity and desire for atrocity
without viewing it through a
metaphysical lens you can't understand
someone like Eric Harris or the
countless others who are possessed so to
speak in exactly the manner that he was
without using dramatic or religious
language because you cannot formulate
either the question nor the answer with
enough profundity without that kind of
representation now I wouldn't say that
the motives that I've discussed
constitute the only reasons for the
human thirst for war but I can tell you
that you'll never understand the desire
for atrocity
without coming to grips with the problem
of evil thank you you're listening to
ideas in Canada on CBC Radio 1 on Sirius
XM across North America and around the
world on CBC CA I'm Paul Kennedy what is
it that drives us to violence murder and
war these are some of the most puzzling
corners of the human personality and
with the help of William Shakespeare and
John Milton psychologist Jordan Peterson
has been exploring the mind of murder
specifically the mind of Columbine
killer Eric Harris this is a history of
violence and time now for my
conversation with Jordan Peterson and
for some audience questions I want to
begin I guess sort of where you began
and I've never heard the words of Eric
Harris before and I have to tell you I
found them chilling ly frightening it
was interesting though to then hear you
quote and had the the quotation so
apposite and so perfect matching quoting
from milton and quoting from Paradise
Lost
I believe my undergraduate memory of
studying that masterpiece is that and I
think this is a school of critical
thought as well
Milton apparently liked Satan more than
he liked any of the other characters in
that and that amazingly weren't a modern
interpretation why would that be modern
and what do you mean by that well
because Milton was a genius and the way
he represented Satan in Paradise Lost
was as a rebel and he didn't paint him
in black and white so to speak he gave
him all the attributes that an admirable
rebel would have and people enjoy
identifying with the figure of the
admirable rebel but what's what Satan
was rebelling against wasn't what an
admirable rebel would rebel against he
wasn't rebelling the way Christ say
rebelled in his time against the
increasing
tendency of the religious state to
become dogmatic and tyrannical Satan was
rebelling against the idea that there
was something that exceeded his power
and that was transcendent while human
beings do that all the time especially
modern human beings so the idea that
that Satan's an admirable character I
think can't be placed at Milton's feet
he opened the door to that
interpretation and that's a good thing
because part of for example the reason
that these modes of thinking were so
powerful and compelling to Harris was
that they allowed him the possibility of
construing himself as an admirable rebel
even though what he was was a momentary
embodiment of the eternal desire to
obliterate everything and those are
characters that exist I mean Eric Harris
is not alone there so he had he had
partners in Columbine he has Admiral at
Meyer is on the web of no small number
and not only does he exist out there he
also exists in here like the thing that
he represents the thing that he embodied
is not it's a it's a permanent element
of the human psyche it's in a radical
it's eternal it's archetypal it's
structural so and why it's structural is
Harris does a good job of explaining
everyone knows that life is tragic and
everyone knows that to exist is to
suffer and one logical and appropriate
response to that is to be grateful in
spite of your suffering and attempt to
make the best of it and perhaps to
alleviate that where you can and another
is to take the perspective of Memphis da
Felice and to say no no the whole
thing's flawed right from the beginning
if this much suffering is the price of
being then we should just eradicate the
whole mess and people think like that
all the time
I'm curious you work not only as an
academic professor of psychology you
also have a practice you have a clinical
practice is there any possible use for
these great icon
of Western or Eastern any literature
which all have in them as you say the
sort of balance or opposition of good
and evil is there any possible clinical
use for that oh if you see people who
are really in trouble like really in
trouble you can't address their problems
without using archetypal language it's
not possible so for example I had a
client who lived in a web of lies that
was pretty much infinite I tried for
years to get to the bottom of it
familial lies the lie was we love you
and we're helping you when the truth was
you should have been born a boy and
we've hated you ever since you were born
but we're not going to tell you that and
we're not gonna let anyone else know
that because we need a facade of
benevolence now and for her this person
to even begin to understand what was
going on in her family there was no
escaping archetypal language I mean it
was hellish people died in that house
and I made very little headway every
time I got to the bottom of some
absolutely horrendous betrayal betrayers
were in Dante's Inferno they were right
in the center of Hell right they were
the worst of the criminal so to speak I
get to the bottom of some god-awful
decades-long brilliantly played betrayal
and there'd be another one at the bottom
of that I was wondering specifically
though whether you'd actually used texts
in in conversation or patients yeah so
you have talked about farce or you know
lots of my patients have come from
religious backgrounds I mean one of them
was a relatively unsuccessful chaplain
who was suddenly fired from her job and
then was hit by a car so that wasn't a
good day um all in one day yes yes and
there was just there was no escaping the
religious dimension I mean the thing
about religious the religious dimension
sits at the bottom of life I mean people
don't understand that they think it's a
set of superstitions it's like it's not
a set of superstitions or if it is then
you might ask yourself a why do you
continue to go see it played out time
and time again on stage
is what are you just entertaining
yourself it's like you're not whether
you know it or not you're educating
yourself you're seeing near archetypal
representations of the structural
elements of human behavior laid out for
you by geniuses dramatically and part of
the reason that you get the information
that way is that no you're not smart
enough to understand it abstractly and
neither is anyone else it's so
complicated that even now all we can
really do is see it played out it's very
difficult for us to transform that into
fully articulated philosophy it took me
15 years of work three hours a day to
develop the ideas that and really like
that was every day I was thinking about
this obsessively for four decades and it
took me that long to reach the level of
articulation where I could tell the sort
of story I told today it's like it's
complicated material and so it's also
predicated on the idea which which I
believe to be true is that reality
itself is a forum for action it's not a
place of objective things and I believe
that I also believe that if you're a
true Darwinian you have to believe that
because Darwin believed that we are
selected for survival as a consequence
of our actions and so our actions are
what actually constitute the fundamental
truth you live or die by your actions
well actions have patterns we have
character we have a nature that's why
you can that's why dramatic
representations can be distributed
worldwide and everyone understands them
and they understand them in some sense
innately and were drawn to them I
remember I showed Pinocchio to my son
when he was about four Pinocchio is a
story about confronting chaos and
rescuing history in order to become a
genuine human being that's Pinocchio
goes to the bottom of the ocean to
confront chaos in the form of a whale
and he rescues his father and that makes
him a fully developed human being that's
a story that the Egyptians told 4000
years ago it's a very old story my son
must watch that third
times you know he was really in some
sense obsessed with it well not really
Pinocchio has so much information and
you can barely begin to calculate it and
you know you could tell that by watching
its effect on someone whose mind was
just starting to develop he was
terrified of that whale but he wouldn't
stop watching it you know we used to
tell him keep your eye on the hero right
because you know what should you show
your children frightening things
well the world is frightening you're
going to shelter them from that then all
you do is launch them out into the world
like like edible prey it's a bad idea so
you know you have to tell the children
what to do and that's to keep your eye
on the hero because despite the fact
that it's dangerous he prevails that's
the story of humanity it's not while the
heroes you know quivering at the back of
the cave you know waiting for someone
else to do the dirty work I guess I'm
wondering how we might take the
archetypes you're talking about in
literature and theater in art and
creative world and somehow connect them
with the other kind of world we're
watching all the time on television and
then as you say we are in a world where
many of these things are being acted out
right right before our eyes and it's
horrifying to watch this is horrifying
to watch television for me these days
anyway as it would be to read Eric
Harris eternal um and how could I
connect what I might learn if you if you
I mean I tried to take apart the reasons
for atrocity and warfare particularly I
was trying to understand how the world
could have come to the point in about
1984 where we were locked in mad right
mutual assured destruction mode thought
how in the world is it that the world
that we could have constituted the world
so that we're aiming at each other's
mutual destruction with a weapon
capacity that was exponentially beyond
that it seemed like a mystery and I
tried different levels of analysis you
know because my first degree was
political science so I tried political
and economic and
and sociological and until I got to the
psychological and then to the
psychodynamic I didn't really have much
luck because you see what I was trying
to understand for example wasn't so much
territorial war you know I can kind of
understand you have something I want it
so you know I'll push you out of the way
animals do that I mean it's it's not
it's by no means right but it's
understandable but there are there are
endless stories say about occurrences in
the 20th century some of them that you
can't even read without developing
post-traumatic stress disorder of
gratuitous violence so one example
that's always haunted me it's an example
from Auschwitz was the game that the
guards used to play there where you know
that the people that were being
incarcerated would rival the camps and
of course they're already terrorized and
half dead or completely dead and ripped
out of their lives and thrown in with
people they don't understand and whose
language they don't speak and demolished
in multiple ways and you know they'd
have them carry wet sacks of salt on
their backs from one side of the
compound to the other and back it's like
okay just exactly why do you want to do
that well that's a messy question you
know and I don't think you can
understand it until you understand
understand the part of you that could do
that and one of the horrifying things
about this line of investigation is that
that part exists and you could
understand it but you probably won't and
it's no bloody wonder so when I started
the psychological investigation I read a
lot of mythology a lot of work on
comparative religion and see the
religious stories are the fundamental
narratives you know they sort of if you
think of behavior or or drama as having
a grammar the
grammar of behavior and drama is
religious and the reason it's related
it's religious because it's the grammar
you know you can't go any deeper than
that that's how things are like the
human being the archetypal human being
is a hero voluntarily confronting the
unknown that's what we are and if we're
not that we're something else and that
is not a good thing
it's also something that and I think
this is what's really interesting about
what you're saying I would would say and
I may be mischaracterizing civilization
or 20th century political reality but
many people I think given the fact you
say it's a fact and I think it is
grounded in something really archetypal
and perhaps really just really basic DNA
there's evil and there's good most
people would want to say okay let's work
on getting rid of evil and I think you
good luck I think you're saying no
that's not what you have to do oh no I
think that is what you have to do but
you don't do it by getting rid of other
people's evil you get you do it by
getting rid of your own like I can tell
you an experiment you can try this is a
great experiment try not to say anything
that isn't true for a month you know and
you say well what about white lies it's
like well you know that's your problem
you see if you can figure out how to
tell so you know you might say your wife
says how do I look in this dress and you
know you don't think she looks very good
and so you say you look great honey and
that's real good but that isn't the
right answer the right answer is
something like don't ask me manipulative
questions yeah I know that's a little
look it's a little harsh a and I
wouldn't actually formulate it that way
I would say well you know I don't answer
questions like that or something like
that so the truth wouldn't be that you
know you look hideous in that dress and
only a would wear it that's that's
not the truth you know the truth is more
sophisticated than that and you know
people are telling lies all the time to
spare other people's feelings and they
have all sorts of good reasons for it's
like there are no good reasons for life
you pollute your speech by lying and one
of the most fundamental presuppositions
of Western culture and this is I think
the most perhaps the most brilliant
disguise
we're human beings ever made is that
chaos is transformed into order by the
word and you are all speakers of the
word and if you want chaos to be
transformed into hell then lie if you
want chaos to be transformed into heaven
then tell the truth fighting evil does
matter but it's not corporations you
know some of them are evil obviously
some of them aren't you know it's not
corporations it's not socio political
structures none of those things it's
like fix up your speech fix up your
family and then if you can manage that
which is very difficult then maybe you
could dare to start thinking about
something more complex than the family
level of organization you know I see
students all the time whose lives are
they're a god-awful mess you know and
they're out protesting about something
that's destroying the world it's like
well if we put you in charge well you
have to decide what you're up to and
you're either trying to make things
better or worse that's it those are the
options and if you're trying to make
them worse there's reason that if you're
trying to make them better there's a
reason and so in some sense you decide
which side you're on and then then you
decide how much you're on that side and
a huge part of being on that side is
truth it's the fundamental virtue
without truth you don't know where you
are you don't know what you're doing you
don't know who you are and the only
reason you think you can get away with
anything is pride it's like you know I'm
smart enough to twist the fabric of
reality in my favor
it's like clear okay go ahead see what
happens it's like the outcome will not
be pretty even if you get what you want
doing that you'll find out that it
doesn't do for you what you thought it
would so you know it's a fool's victory
first question from the audience do
people tend to take from plays views
that reinforce their own position even
when the play expresses
country oh that's a good that's a really
good question art and literature truly
subversive and in the in you know
because first of all if it's art it's
not propaganda because if it's
propaganda then that's a conscious
attempt to change the way you think or
look but if it's art then what's
happening is the artist is trying to
figure something out
well he or she is engaged in the act of
artistic production and then the art
object is the result of that exploratory
attempt and the thing about exploring
with art is you're always exploring
things that you don't know because
otherwise why would you be exploring and
so part of the reason that art is
subversive is because it exists on the
border between articulated knowledge and
the unknown itself like it's the place
where articulated knowledge is born and
it's very difficult to criticize art
right I mean you could say well one
painting is better than another but like
what I mean by that is even nihilistic
punk rockers like music right music
seeps in it's like music helps them
celebrate life to the degree that
nihilistic punk rockers are capable of
doing that and they won't criticize the
music like maybe they don't like the
lyrics or whatever but you're just an
idiot if you criticize music as a
phenomenological entity like dance is
the same way these things are in some
sense they're beyond criticism because
you actually don't know what they're
about
so yeah art is really subversive or
transformative you know but that's the
same thing this is a question that
brings us right up to the present day I
suppose what should be done in Gaza how
do we look at that conflict properly I
don't have an answer for that I don't
think there's anything I can do about
Gaza or alternatively I'm doing
everything I can about Gaza by talking
to you here today and my conclusion was
as I mentioned before when I was trying
to figure out what level of analysis was
appropriate to conceptualize the
greatest of moral problems so Gaza
situation is a good example of that
I always ended up at the individual
level so I would say if you want to help
the situation in Gaza be more truthful
with your spouse and you'd think well
how can that be connected but I can tell
you how it's connected you know you're
more connected to other people than you
think so you know we don't live in
linear relationships with one another we
live in networked relationships so each
of you is connected for example pretty
directly to about a thousand people over
the course of your life thousand people
it's more than that probably but then
you think well you are connected to a
thousand so that's a million so you're
one person away from a million people
and then those thousand thousand no a
thousands and so you're two people away
from a billion people and you know the
thing that's interesting about a network
is that it has as many centers as there
are nodes and one of the this is
something Solzhenitsyn made explicit but
one of the implicit presuppositions of
the judeo-christian tradition is that
each soul is a center of the cosmos you
think what can that be true it's like
god only knows what's true what we know
about consciousness you could put in a
thimble we know nothing about
consciousness we haven't advanced in our
understanding fact we may have gone
backwards over the last 400 years like I
mean we know nothing about the
relationship of the brain to conscious
awareness or virtually nothing bits and
pieces here and there
consciousness is an absolute mystery and
god only knows where it came from or
what it's up to I mean we we know some
things about human being we are
fundamentally explorers of the unknown
that's how we're built we take things
apart and put them together and you know
when we communicate the results of that
and we find pleasure in that but don't
underestimate the utility of getting
your life together
I mean besides you can do that besides
you're not going to hurt anyone if you
do that you'll just make things better
plus it's kind of humble it's like you
can sweep underneath your bed you know
you don't have to go out and wave a
placard around I'm against poverty it's
like who's for poverty you know so
I think you want to fix the world fix
your life it's a lot harder than you
think right it says in the New Testament
it's harder to rule yourself than to
rule the city but why well it turns out
you're more complicated than a city it
also turns out that you're more
important in some sense than a city and
it also turns out to matter what you do
with your life not it matters for you
and it matters for everyone else and it
probably matters for the destiny of
being I mean that's what it means in
some sense to be made in God's image and
you know you think well I don't take
that stuff very seriously it's like your
whole legal system is predicated on that
idea so don't you say and you don't take
it seriously you know you you presume
that you have intrinsic value
it's a presupposition right well what is
intrinsic value mean it's grounded in
something it's transcendent value and
even if you don't believe in it you act
it out and you'll be very annoyed if
anybody interferes with your
transcendent value so who cares what you
say we you believe what do you know
about yourself you know we wouldn't have
psychology if we were transparent to
ourselves we wouldn't have drama you
know just because you believe something
about who you are it doesn't make it
true
so take it
this is back to Michael to Eric Harris
what parenting or educational practices
help to develop such extreme arrogance
is displayed by somebody like Eric
Harris it's not self-evident that it was
parenting per se that produced Harris
you know and I would hesitate to lay
responsibility at his parents feet
people make choices and this is a rough
one day because we don't have the
science for that because the science
says well it's got to be causal in some
factor so you look at sociological or
economic causes and you know there's all
these deterministic events on the social
side and on the natural side nature and
nurture that's all you are is nature
nurture it's like well maybe not euros
actually nature nurture and
consciousness and consciousness seems to
be able to make choices and the choices
seem to matter so you can come from a
pretty wretched family and a pretty
wretched social circumstance where
absolutely everything is stacked against
you and come out pretty damn good
most people who abuse their children
were abused as children
causal right well know most people who
were abused as children don't abuse
their children the causality only works
when you go from the abuse back okay so
that the pool of abuse people is high
most of them don't abuse their children
but if you look at child abusers small
pool most of them were abused but you're
not talking about the whole continuum
most people who were abused don't abuse
and men you know that because if they
did think about it if they did it would
spread exponentially and then everyone
would be being raised by seriously
violent abusive parents and it would
take no time at all I can take a few
generations and poof
everyone would be a violent abuser it's
like that doesn't happen so weirdly
enough the horrors of history don't
necessarily accumulate and become
transferred and I've seen this in my own
practice like I
one client who she had a pretty nasty
upbringing her mother pretty much did
everything she possibly could to make
sure that she had no real
self-confidence and what she learned
from that was not to do that to her son
and she raised an excellent son it's
like she had every reason to you know
perpetuate her misery as a consequence
of resentment and she has some
resentment and it's not surprising but
she swore man I'm gonna not I'm not
going to do this to my son and she did a
great job like I know her can't quite
well and he's uh she didn't over protect
him that's pretty good he tells the
truth he's he's on a career you know
he's got his career going
he's a straightforward young guy and he
likes his mom you know so good deal but
account for that causally the problem is
and this is something Nietzsche observed
a long time ago any event can produce
multiple causal pathways well not any
event but you know any complex event so
determinism I think the world is too
complicated to be deterministic so
on ideas you've been listening to a
history of violence
an exploration by psychologist Jordan
Peterson into the human lust for
violence and killing on YouTube you can
find many of us talks at jordan Peterson
videos this program was recorded at the
Studio Theatre of the Stratford Festival
thanks to michael hart robin Cheeseman
melissa renault Peter Holland and David
Campbell special thanks to ants word
feiger Anthony tulino and Keira Loughran
if you want to find out more about the
show and what's coming up or to comment
on anything you heard in the show check
us out at our website CDC CA slash ideas
and you can also find us on Facebook and
Twitter a history of violence was
produced by Philip Coulter the executive
producer of ideas Greg Kelly I'm Paul
Kennedy the hourly news is next
you